oh hey guys i'm abby sharp welcome to
Abby's kitchen so a little confession
time here folks
zucchinis don't make pasta I mean they
don't make real pasta you know like
you're not only probably pretty pissed
if you came home and told her you made
pasta out of a vegetable and that it was
great but you know having said that I
think that zucchini noodles are pretty
rad all in their own right they're never
gonna replace a perfectly al dente bowl
of fettuccine
but they taste really good and they help
you get your vegetables in and most
importantly guys they leave a little
caloric wiggle room for some extra bread
wine and cheese and that my friends is
what we call a superfood so I wanted to
share with you the number one recipe on
the abbot's kitchen blog zucchini noodle
carbonara so first I'm going to show you
how to make a non soggy zucchini noodle
this is like the number one thing that
people complain about when it comes to
these noodle recipes that's the
affectionate little pet name we have for
these little nuggets we're going to
start to spiralize this and here's the
dealio zucchinis they're mainly water so
the thing we got to do is try to get the
water out the way we go about that is by
a little grade 11 science lecture that's
Moses so when we put a little salt on
top of our zucchini noodles it draws the
moisture out in an effort to reach
equilibrium equilibrium equilibrium all
right now let's get cooking so I start
by lightly sprinkling the zoodles with a
little bit of salt to help draw out the
water then I press them with a few
sheets of paper towels and I let it sit
for about 10 minutes after 10 minutes i
rinsed them off with cold water and lay
them back on a fresh sheet of paper
towel to dry top with a few more layers
of paper towel and some heavy items and
let them dry for another 10 minutes
so next we turn those you
noodles into my all-time favorite
comfort food dish pasta carbonara
so honestly folks I usually cannot
justify making a pasta carbonara on a
usual night it's basically just eggs
cheese bacon and a ton of carbs but when
you're using zucchini noodles mm-hmm I'm
like getting all the bacon so in a bowl
I'd beat together two eggs an egg yolk
and some Parmesan cheese and I set that
aside heat a large skillet over medium
heat and add one teaspoon of oil then
you add the pancetta cook it until crisp
and remove the bacon into a small dish
and return the pan to the stove add in
some more olive oil and bring the pan
back to a medium heat saute some minced
shallots for about two minutes then add
in some minced garlic for a minute next
add in the peas and stir until pretty
much thought through finally add in the
zucchini increase the heat to
medium-high and saute for just two to
three minutes or until fully warmed
through turn off the heat and toss the
zoodles with the egg cheese mixture for
no more than two minutes add in the
bacon and season with freshly cracked
black pepper top with some extra cheese
for good measure
and enjoy so guys I am so excited to dig
in so I'm going to get to that but what
I want you guys to do is to leave me a
comment below but your favorite comfort
foods are and that way I'm going to do a
little dish do-over with them in an
upcoming video so definitely leave me a
comment subscribe to the channel if you
like this video give me the thumbs up
and I'll see you next time on Abby's
kitchen